bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7-8 sport
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
handball équipes féminines de montillot
bretonneau a réalisé une incroyable
performance lors de son premier match en
nationale une
promu cette saison dans cette division
lésigny montaigne se sont imposés contre
landi lampaul sur le score de 28 à 24
nous recevrons dans cette émission les
joueuses saint-quentinoise rugby montier
bretons ne recevaient colomiers pour le
premier match de la saison de 1re série
et montigny a perdu de justesse premier
match sur le score de 25 à 20 les
détails dans ce magazine football on
jouera le week-end prochain le 4e tour
de la coupe de france il y aura
notamment un derby sulfureux entre
trappe qui évolue en promotion d'honneur
et versailles qui est en dh
coup de projecteur a su dans cette
édition sur ce grand rendez vous et puis
enfin l'émission comme tous les lundis
vous retrouverez tous les résultats
sportifs du week-end dans le département
il y aura notamment du lou rugby avec
chevreuse et du football avec le match
montigny contre trappe
les joueuses de mon team automnaux
réussi leurs débuts promu cette année en
nationale une les filles coachées par
philippe les tranches se sont imposés à
domicile contre laon d'ilop lampaul sur
le score de 28 à 24
pour nous parler de cette brillante
victoire l'euro se vend sur ce plateau
trois joueuses de montigny la demi
centre mathilde aux rides à l'arrière
gauche loup bénézis la pivot amende une
passe et bonsoir alors racontez nous un
petit peu ce premier match à amandine
bas c est pas trop stresse un peu de
stress forcément puisque c'était le
premier match on était
enfin plusieurs joueuses qui
découvraient ce niveau là
après je pense que c'était une pression
positive et on était surtout très
impatiente d'entrer dans le championnat
vous l'avez préparée comment ce match et
v il y avait peut-être plus d'engouement
que d'habitude au niveau des
entraînements il y avait plus
d'intensité
c'est sûr que l'intensité au niveau des
entraînements c'est monté crescendo
depuis le début de la prépa au mois
d'août après on a quand même une
préparation sérieuse et rigoureuse et
puis on a été régulière tout le monde la
préparation pour être prête aujourd'hui
championnat lou finalement vous l'avez
plutôt bien enfin vous avez réussi un
super match où il avait remporté assez
facilement facilement je dirais pas ça
on a quand même joué notre handball on a
réussi à être efficace même si une
équipe qu'on ne connaissait pas et on a
réussi à imposer notre jeu a montré
qu'en défense sont été présenté une
autre attaque a été fluide et on a
réussi à montrer que monty n'était là
mathilde qu'est ce qu'il y avait ce qui
a fonctionné dans ce match c'est
vraiment la taxe et ça vous avez marqué
28 points
vous êtes la petite nouvelle finalement
vous avez trouvé une équipe qui
fonctionne bien au niveau offensif a
alors je dirais que ça a commencé plutôt
au niveau défensif
je pense qu'on a vraiment gagné le match
en première mi-temps sur la défense
vraiment après on a trouvé quand même
pas mal de solutions offensives
on a encore beaucoup de travail là
dessus mais la défense déjà c'était
vraiment un gros point positif pour ce
début de championnat
amandine va c est un défi de landi
lampaul sont arrivés avec 45 minutes de
retard
finalement vous avez accepté de jouer ce
match quand même finalement vous êtes
une équipe plutôt fair play exactement
non c'est vrai que
on aurait pu gagner le match en fait
d'office mme skalli heures 30 elle
n'était pas présente
après on a préféré gagner avec la
manière et et puis c'était aussi une
occasion pour nous de se jauger effet de
d'entamer le championnat d'une bonne
façon donc
et pourquoi avoir accepté justement de
jeu quand même ce match même si la
victoire était acquise
de toute façon la décision d'une rente
n'est pas nous c'est les dirigeants qui
ont décidé puis c'est vrai que c'est une
équipe qu'on a rencontré déjà en
nationale 2 il ya deux ans et avec qui
on s'entend plutôt bien on est toujours
bien accueilli la balle sont bien
accueillis chez nous donc si on avait
été à leur place je pense qu'on aurait
été contente de que le match soit
repoussée de trois quarts d'heure lou
est ce qu'on peut dire que cette
victoire va créer une cohésion de groupe
ça va mettre en place des fondamentaux
pour les matches suivants
c'est sûr et certain de notre notre
équipe va être beaucoup plus soudé après
cette victoire surtout après un match
comme celui ci où on a dû attendre une
équipe qui n'arrivaient pas
donc ça nous a soudé ça nous a
rapprochés que ce soit en dehors ou sur
le tard et ça peut montrer à toute
équipe peut-être que montigny finalement
il faudra compter sur cette équipe cette
année
exactement notre équipe sera présente
nous montons de nationale 2 mais on
montre qu'on est pour mathilde maintenir
va-t-il vous êtes convaincus par ça
aussi ça va montrer aux autres équipes
que montigny peu peut aller finalement
loin dans cette nationale complètement
et je pense que la première journée de
championnat est vraiment très importante
est d'avoir vraiment gagné ce week end
je pense que c'est on joue le maintien
donc tous les points vont être
importants donc c'était vraiment
une belle victoire et ce premier match
de la saison finalement amandine passé
il fallait remporter
c'était obligatoire il fallait remporter
celui-là we dare déjà pour pour se
mettre dans le bain rapidement et puis
il me semble que lundi était en bas de
tableau l'année dernière et donc je
pense que ça va être un candidat dans la
course au maintien comme nous donc
c'était déjà important de s'imposer face
à elle et après il faut pas s'emballer
non plus la saison est encore longue il
ya encore des grosses équipes à venir
mais c'est un bon début
il ya un recrutement également qu'elle
était fait avec vous mathilde par
exemple nous allons justement écouter
votre entraîneur philippe étrange
à ce sujet il ya eu des bons
recrutements avec nos mots nos petits
moyens on est la france l'équipe là
niveau budget la plus petite de la poule
e même peut-être de la nationala dont
contrats ont fait avec c'est pas grave
on a eu deux on a bien recruté avec des
filles qu'on est allé chercher deux
niveaux supérieurs et des jeunes qui
montent donc l' amalgame se fait bien
maintenant bon ça fait vingt-cinq fois
qu'on s'est vus là depuis le 17 août
on a besoin de faire des vrais matchs
pour
on se juger quoi je joue j'ai loup est
ce que vous êtes d'accord avec votre
coach philippe étrange
finalement cette équipe elle a besoin de
se jauger sur sur les prochains matches
exactement on a l'effectif par la
qualité d'effectif ce justement se
jaugera sur les prochains matches oui on
doit prouver encore qu'on est con c'est
jouer ensemble il ya eu des joueuses
comme philippe l'a dit qui ont été
recrutés on a encore un peu de mal à
jouer ensemble mais avec les
entraînements et avec la cohésion de
groupe à mon avis ça devrait très bien
se passer et vous matilda comment vous
sentez vous cette équipe mais d'arriver
il ya quelques semaines me sentais comme
on m'a dit je me sens très bien j'étais
vraiment très bien accueilli
je pense que la cohésion et l'ambiance
va faire beaucoup puisque ça va être
compliqué hein faut pas se le cacher
donc non pour l'instant tout se passe
bien on voit là il faut continuer à
travailler et trouver une certaine
régularité puis ça devrait voilà dix ans
passés et qu'est ce qui vous a poussé
justement voir rejoindre entier cette
année le challenge national et une les
gros matches 1 1
c'est un changement et un nouveau départ
un nouveau projet qui m'intéressait
beaucoup je jouais dans une équipe qui
jouait le haut classement voire la
montée en d2 donc du coup c'est très
différent mais justement l'une ce
nouveau challenge je le prends à coeur
et j'espère apporter le plus possible
pour réussir à se maintenir
amandine va c'est ce que l'équipe est
plus forte que la scène aurait vraiment
il ya plus de qualité dans cet effectif
alors c'est sûr qu'on sait qu'on s'est
renforcé sur des postes importants en
plus je pense à mathilde en 2000 sans
toit dans les buts aussi dans les buts
avec simona ou même bianca sur le poste
d'arrière gauche qui doublent très bien
avec lui après il ya encore des
automatismes à trouver mais c'est normal
ça va ça peut pas venir tout de suite
voilà ça va venir en petit à petit mais
finalement ça a bien fonctionné sur
premier match
oui voilà premier match ça a bien
fonctionné on s'emballe pas on continue
à travailler
lou quel est l'objectif cette année et
maintient le maintiens absolument pas
plus haut on va attendre peut-être un
petit peu avant de se lancer dans la d2
on a un collectif qui doit se maintenir
en l1 et je pense qu'on cherchera pas
plus loin pour la première année les
prochains objectifs c'est peut-être dans
schelin c'est la victoire
oui ce serait ça serait très simple et
donc à l'avenir
vous pensez que l'effectif peut
justement vous vous sentez vraiment que
cet effectif peut avoir le maintien
français pas qu'il est peut-être un peu
trop jeunes là où pensez vous à gagner
en expérience peut-être j'y viens
expérience oui oui parce que évidemment
je joue avec des joueuses qui sont de
bon niveau qui ont évolué à des niveaux
supérieurs qu'ils m'apportent dans mon
jeu qui me donne des conseils et c est
le fait qu on est une équipe jeune fait
que notre maintien peut être assurée
dans le sens où l'on peut on peut
prétendre à augmenter notre niveau en
fonte fil des années merci à vous cas
d'être passé sur ce plateau encore bravo
pour cette première victoire donc dans
la seine en nationale une
on passe à présent ballon ovale nous
avons parlé un rugby
au rugby et montigny-le-bretonneux n'a
pas eu la même réussite que les
handballeuses
iny monteyne pour leur premier match de
la saison en 1re série les saint
quentinois se sont inclinés de justesse
contre colomiers sur le score de 25 à 20
à match pourtant à leur portée roma
russe finit à pour le montage l'histoire
se répète pour montigny le bretonneux
lésigny montain débuté leur saison de
première série par une défaite
le même scénario qu'en 2014 et cette
fois-ci leur bourreau s'appelle
coulommiers les joueurs de
seine-et-marne ont remporté le match de
justesse sur le score de 25 à 20 dans
une rencontre musclée dont il n'y a
pourtant inscrit trois essais dans la
partie a failli remporter le match dans
les dernières secondes
sigean rageant de perdre de peu mais
surtout en france s'étaient bien
préparés on s'était dit on veut pas
faire comme la saison dernière et rater
le premier match et galérer toute la
saison après pour chercher les victoires
après je pense qu'on a tout donné donc
on ne peut pas être très déçu par le
résultat
pénalité ratée en avant mais les perdu
lésiné montant commis trop de fautes
pour espérer remporter une victoire face
au deuxième de la saison dernière on a
manqué de coordination douche
donc il ya beaucoup de réglages à faire
à ce niveau là parce que quand appâter
ballon je suis deg point de lancement
comme la touche mais tu peux pas rentrer
je jouais beaucoup donc on a manqué
beaucoup de réalisme à ce niveau là on
n'est pas encore prêt avant la saison
vient de commencer
mais après on s'est tous donné c'était
physique et comme ils sont plus lourds
c'est sur la fin du match ça va c'est
plusieurs pour nous parce que ça ça tape
c'est ça nous fatigue plus vite on
fatigue plus vite que parce qu'ils sont
toujours et du coup ce qui nous a manqué
sur la france pour tout physique
prochain match pour montigny le
bretonneux dimanche prochain contre
senlis à l'extérieur lésigny montain
devront l'emporter pour continuer à
rêver de la montée en promotion
d'honneur
après le ballon ovale le ballon rond
coup de projecteur sur le football et la
coupe de france on jouera ce week-end le
4e tour de la coupe de france le tirage
au sort a accouché d'un choc yvelinois
le derby entre trappe qui évolue en
promotion d'honneur et versa qui évolue
trois divisions dessus en dh pour nous
parler de ce match on recevra en plateau
le président de trappes mustapha
larbaoui le coach de l'équipe seniors
hommes au china aussi l'arrière droit
hamidou sissoko bonsoir du sang alors
motion est ce que ce tirage contre
versailles c'est un bon ou un mauvais
tirage
c'est un bon tiens je me sens coupe de
france hier pas mauvaises choses à
moitié il faut tous les jouer des
matches c'est ça tous les matchs où vous
êtes d'accord d'accord que la coupe de
france il ya une spécificité à la coupe
vous pouvez mettre une équipe de
cinquième division contre nous et on
peut le perdre
alors que sur le papier ça sera l
inverse et en même temps jouer
versailles qui est un qui est une très
très belle équipe qui évolue en dh
donc trois niveaux au dessus pour ceux
qui connaissent pas les classements donc
c'est d'autant plus intéressant que ça
reste un effectivement un derby mais
c'est comme le dit mme chan tous les
matches de coupe de france sont
intéressants il ya une spécificité à la
coupe de france et en même temps ça
reste nos amis ça reste nos adversaires
sportif et nous avons des trappistes
depuis très longtemps qui évolue
également à versailles donc voilà c'est
une manière de rencontrer le bon niveau
et c'est ça qui nous intéresse avant
tout hamidou sissoko est ce que vous
joueurs vous êtes heureux d'avoir tiré à
versailles heureux oui c'est un derby
vous arrivez discuter un petit peu entre
vous bien sûr ça
retrouvez comme zé président du joueur
trappistes après nous on va jouer sans
pression c'est un match c'est du plus on
joue et ça va donner donc c'est jouable
bien sûr bien sûr évidemment c est
justement mon chien comment allez vous
préparer ce match
il se prépare peut-être un petit peu
différemment d'un match de championnat
classique où nous est ce qu'il y aura
peut-être je sais pas peut-être un peu
plus de séances de tirs au but par
exemple non parce que c'est un an
on va le préparer comme un match qu'on
doit préparer va rien changer à nos
habitudes pour ce match là on aurait
tiré une 5e div où une quatrième du nom
ne réfère à la même préparation c'est
pas la priorité est clairement montré la
porte
si une chose qui va changer clairement
on va s'y préparer différemment des
autres matchs ces problèmes en aura
beaucoup plus de monde dans les tribunes
donc c'est la fête donc à ce titre là on
fera en sorte que dans les tribunes
voilà on soit bien accueillie et que
tout le monde profite de cette journée
comme une fête du football parce que
globalement on a pas mal de monde dans
les tribunes à tous nos matches surtout
depuis qu'ils gagnent tous leurs matches
il faut fonctionner février c'est ça à
peu près tout février dernier une belle
victoire assez ils sont sur une belle
belle série
et puis le début de saison ils ont fait
magnifique entame de saison ça va super
bien j'en profite pour les saluer le ici
mais tous ceux qui qui nous regarde les
joueurs et également les familles ça
bosse c'est impressionnant comme ses
studios comme ces volontaires comme ils
sont dedans
vous voilà donc sur le plan du football
match on l'a dit ça sera un match comme
un autre
allez dans les tribunes je pense qu'on
aura un peu plus de monde et il faut
juste que ça reste un plaisir et une
fête du football il n'ya pas quand même
un petit regret d'avoir tiré peut-être
mme ashton à une équipe qui a finalement
trois divisions puisque vous est ce
qu'il n'ya pas ce petit regret de se
dire finalement il aurait pu aller un
petit peu plus loin ou pas non ya pas de
regret postulat de regrets mais on va
aller aussi loin c'est pas une priorité
après là on a tiré vers ça et unsa est
une belle opposition et en coupe de
france il ya pas de petites équipes
c'est ça qui est bien on va qui magie en
coupe de france et les joueurs vous vous
en pensez quoi
ben nous on y croit on n'a pas peur de
façon pour aller au bout faut passer par
les grandes équipes que ce soit
maintenant ou après le petit poucet que
les téléspecteurs connaissent bien le
petit coup d'oeil il sort bien à un
moment donné des éliminatoires où les
petites équipes entre guillemets il n'y
a pas de petites équipes surtout sur des
événements comme ça ils se retrouvent en
aval avec des équipes de ligue 1 alors
qu'ils sont en cfa et il le différencier
de même alors on n'a pas cette volonté
de fer stade de france on a juste envie
de jouer les matches comme ils viennent
bien moment de la détention de vous la
ramenez la coupe de france on prétend
satrape la seule prétention c'est de
montrer le travail qu'ils font et ce
travail là il est bon et il finit par
payer et au football ça se traduit par
des victoires au gagne bah ça sera le
niveau on perd et ben ça sera un niveau
et continuer à travailler
hamidou est ce que vous n'êtes pas non
plus aussi revanchard par rapport à
l'année dernière vous étiez
finalement vous avez été éliminée assez
tôt l'année dernière cette année
peut-être qu'on pouvait l'être un peu
plus loin est ce que est ce que
justement vous n'êtes pas un peu
revanchard par rapport à ça tu dire
cette année finalement ça peut être
votre année le championnat après comme
on dit les matchs de cohérence et sa
base du plus surtout face à des équipes
comme celle là ça va nous faire sur une
permet de travailler en plus donc nous
sans pression et jouer crânement notre
chance et cette année aussi on a
remarqué que vous avez mieux on va dire
en année votre votre votre début de
saison
l'année dernière c'était un peu
compliqué cette année vous avez gagné
contre villemomble 3 et contre clichy 7
à 2 mais finalement quoi vous avez un
potentiel offensif énorme et on sent
aussi vous êtes concentré dès ce début
de championnat mais aussi parce que
c'est le même groupe que l'année
dernière un ou deux joueurs près donc on
est aussi sur la dynamique de la saison
dernière et je pense que cette année
avec le départ qu'on a pris faut pas
qu'on a chez rien et à qui on n'est qu'à
deux journées mais bon bien commencé
c'est toujours important
moi je tienne la montée cette année
l'objectif principal c'est de se
maintenir très rapidement après si on
doit jouer dans monté en un jour on voit
qu'il ya des joueurs quand même qui ont
marqué ce début de saison je pense par
exemple à la samba je crois qui est
cliquée ton frère est devant justement
il a apporté enfin il a marqué
énormément de buts là depuis ce début de
saison
est-ce que c'est lui qui peut vous
porter peut-être en coupe de france
justement réalisé un exploit maïs bien
6,6 à deux cent voix qui va très vite en
sur le fond la taille normale c'est
clair c'est un jeune qui nous apporte sa
fougue son insouciance
après nous avec notre expérience on va
faire ainsi de faire un mix pour pour je
suis à deux doigts de rebaptiser c'est
pour l'étoile sportive de table c'est
l'étoile si son compte c'est qu'il est
majeur dans le onze de départ
il est majeur dans la défense donc il ya
une défense aussi il
il y contribue beaucoup et deux frères
devant donc ses sambas et bâle a donc
ses limites qu'on va et puis encore un
petit frère en 19 qui fait kiffer un cas
un talent fou donc oui la famille
cissokho vers famille sissoko pour le
coup on peut rendre aux mains
attrape-tout monde les connaît il faut
un boulot exceptionnel et pas simplement
des buteurs ou des défenseurs des types
bien c'est ça qui est important tous nos
gars sont et un son bien à bien des
égards ça je tiens à préciser
voilà un peu pour redonner un peu de
baume au coeur à tous les gens qui
aiment le foot on regarde des incidents
qui peut y avoir dans des terrains qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le foot vient de
préciser quand et vous mostafa comment
vous le sentez se trame de cette année
vous le sentez plus fort moins fort que
l'année dernière
chaque année chaque année je sens les
choses allaient dans le bon sens et
c'est le propre du du changement dans la
durée c'est le propre du changement dans
la continuité c'est le propre du travail
scellant mais ça paie et en l'occurrence
depuis depuis maintenant plus de dix ans
et
hamidou pour le coup est là depuis le
premier joueur depuis la présidence on
voit bien que ça évolue bien ça évolue
et vous l'avez dit ce début de saison il
est marqué par encore une fois la
continuité du travail de l'an dernier
des apports de quelques joueurs m'ont
arrêté c'est l'esprit de l'an dernier
qui perdure c'est l'esprit est l'équipe
qui est dans la continuité
et bien sûr je vois la différence chaque
année mais je la vois pas simplement
chez les seniors je la vois chez les 19
chez les 17 chez les 15 puisque ce
week-end sept matches ce dimanche 7
matches u17 u15 seniors vétérans sept
matches sept victoires
alors bien sûr c'est qu'un week-end
c'est qu'un dimanche simplement on sent
que ça ça évolue mais bon voilà ce sera
un pli buzz s'ils sont sérieux ils sont
concentrés qu'ils aiment le foot ils
aiment leur art c'est un art et le
pratique comme ça et pour ramener cette
coupe de france peut-être à trappes
il faudra un gros public c'est ça un
grand public c'est pas l'objectif
hamidou le disais c'est pas un objectif
en soi comme le disait notre chaîne
c'est ça fait partie de la préparation
de l'année la coupe de france est un
plus on est sur le championnat
concentrer sur le championnat mais tous
les matches se valent
on a fait des matches avant la saison
n'a fait également des matches amicaux
tous les matchs se valent on lâche on
lâche rien et un crayon et augmenter
sursauter république évidemment pour
pour ça c'est pour ça que disait que
dans les tribunes c'est aussi ce qui
fait la différence
on parle du douzième homme le public il
fera la différence dimanche la
différence y contribuera voilà en étant
calme et serein il ya un match d'hier
qui s'est interrompu à cause d'un public
donc c'est à la fois ça peut être
toxique comme ça peut être très
bénéfique et attrapes c'est toujours
bénéfique
le public est toujours là un public de
connaisseurs ils savent ce qu'ils font
ils aiment le foot ils aiment leur ville
ils aiment leur maillot et donc ça se
passera bien
on les invite à venir ce week-end
j'espère que le message est passé et
merci à tous les trois en tout cas elle
est passée sur ce plateau bonne chance
pour ce quatrième tour et j'espère qu'on
retrouvera pour le tour suivant
si je peux le faire jouer ou pas les
féminines puisque dès la première année
et on a déjà 45 licenciées féminines
c'est vraiment tout nouveau s'offre aux
neuf et on lance l'académie le 15 mai
sera sûrement l'objet d'un reportage
dans son avis et bientôt on passe
maintenant reste de l'actualité sportive
du week end
on commence cette page résultats par du
football en première division de
district un derby saint quentinois était
programmé ce week end
montigny-le-bretonneux l'un des favoris
de la montée en excellence au sommet
l'équipe réserve de trappes au stade de
la coudre et ce sont les trappistes qui
ont créé la sensation lors de cette
deuxième journée en allant l'emporter
chez leurs voisins sur le score de 5
buts à 1
après une bonne première mi-temps les
trappistes ont rapidement mené au score
1 à 0 mais c'est en seconde période que
montigny a pris le bouillon face aux
deux attaquants adverses et ils ont
encaissé trois buts en l'espace de cinq
minutes
on écoute les réactions on est tombé sur
un bon adversaire
on y va dépasser à peu près dans tous
dans l'intensité dans les duels
techniquement boîte ou mérite
reviens saison est encore longue c'est
le deuxième match donc aujourd'hui on
n'en pas avec une bonne valise j'espère
qu'on va apprendre de cette défaite
on pourrait faire tout un inventaire a
pas mal de choses à revoir mais non il
nous a manqué vraiment de tout
techniquement tactiquement c'était passé
n'est pas bon
le score un peu un peu sévère quand même
je trouve parce que on a insisté sur les
coups de pied arrêtés on a senti que
c'était plutôt fébrile là dessus après
montigny a quand même bien bien manier
le ballon et c'est vrai que on a fini
par conclure et ce qu'il a ce qu'il a
fait je pense très mal ces lettres
enquête quatre buts qu'on enchaîne tout
de suite derrière pour plier score en
début de deuxième
à montigny l on avait un avis souvent du
mal et du coup là on espère repartir
pour une belle série très prochainement
du côté du classement l'équipe réserve
de trappes se retrouvent cinquièmes du
championnat après sa belle très belle
victoire contre montigny
il devance aisément tant la différence
de buts le classement est dominé par
plaisir et vélizy qui totalise six
points avec un match nul et une et une
victoire en deux matches dans le bas du
classement bouquet bois d'arcy ferme la
marche avec 2 défaites depuis le début
de la saison on passe rugby en fédérale
3 chevreuse promis cette année a été
dépassé dans tous les compartiments du
jeu par drancy lors de la première
journée du championnat les chevrotins
ont été lourdement mais logiquement
battu 31,7 à domicile par une équipe de
drancy qui était tout simplement trop
forte
malgré cette défaite chevreuse espère
réaliser une grande saison cette année
on écoute le demi centre géré 1040
bellec et le coach brice un très bon
call et cette division n'est joué dans
cette vidéo depuis pas mal d'années on
aurait sans doute fait une erreur et on
a monté directement donc enfin un autre
niveau
pas toujours une pression toujours
l'impression l'appréhension de désir
jean tony oulaï crois j'y suis allé je
suis descendu qu'est ce qui va se passer
pour nous maintenant elle sait jouer
sans pression au sein des armées mais
vaillants et solidaire donc oui à tout
ce qu'il faut pour régler pour se
maintenir
on va jouer la qualif après l'objectif
club en général c'est le maintien
forcément mais sur moi jouer l iphone on
va essayer de gagner tous les matches
direction à présent l'angleterre pour
notre zoom sur la coupe du monde toutes
les phases de jeu n'était pas parfaite
mais le quinze de france s'est
finalement posé contre l'italie sur le
score de 32 à 10 à twickenham le
trappistes hédi ben arous et l'ancien
chai neziri louis picamoles était
titulaire dans les rangs des français
pour cette rencontre
ce dernier a même été désigné homme du
match nous avons recueilli les réactions
des clubs illinois sur l'équipe de
france à la sortie des vestiaires
l'équipe de france assez pauvre assez
pauvre l'essentiel est d'avoir gagné ça
a été fait et je constate que toutes les
équipes ont du mal à démarrer la coupe
du monde les anglais ayant eu du mal les
sud africains encore plus
donc finalement c'était pas si mal s'ils
vont passer de la phase de poules après
on était sonné un pays est capable d'un
exploit contre n'importe qui donc après
c'est le seul avantage du rugby du sport
que c'est plutôt là bas je pensais bien
après l'équipe de france en soit je
trouve on est un peu en retard par
rapport aux autres équipes au niveau du
jeu du rugby moderne et tournée un peu
en retard notamment au niveau des
trois-quarts et tu penses que la france
allait jusqu'aux quarts de finale si on
dort en compte la nouvelle zélande et
sinon demi finale l'équipe de france
affrontera la roumanie mercredi prochain
or handball masculin le che néo promu en
nationale 2 disputé son premier match de
la saison contre boulogne billancourt
l'un des favoris pour la montée il n'y a
pas eu de n'y a pas eu de miracle dans
cette confrontation les yvelinois se
sont largement inclinés à l'extérieur
malgré de bonnes combinaisons
l'attaquent
score final 36 à 29 pour boulogne
billancourt prochain match pour le ch
est né le 4 octobre contre lake
granville une équipe qu'ils recevront
chez eux au gymnase de nouvelle france à
l'occasion des journées du patrimoine le
golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines a organisé la quatrième édition
de son golf festival d activité gratuite
était organisée de 14h à minuit dans la
structure objectif de ce rendez vous
faire découvrir ce sport aux débutants
et novices ont pu s'essayer au putting
c'est-à-dire au jeu court ou encore au
practice du jour et en plein jour et en
plein nuit aimerait que courteille
chargée de projet à la casse qui nous
présente cette journée golfique
on a pu organiser ses visites sur ce
site qui a une histoire plutôt
exceptionnel depuis louis xiv et avec
une évolution jusqu'à la ryder cup 2018
et puis potentiellement les jeux
olympiques 2024 il ya beaucoup de
familles du coup c'est intéressant parce
que les familles découvrent qu'ils
peuvent jouer à la fois les adultes avec
les enfants ils peuvent jouer ensemble
sur le parcours ils peuvent jouer
ensemble au practice
il ya des débutants effectivement et
mais en fait on y lit à tout le monde
quoi y'a famille golfeurs des copains
voilà c'est vraiment pour tous
au total plus de 500 parties personnes
ont participé à cette manifestation
c'est la fin de ce set 8 sport merci
d'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une très
belle soirée sur tv fil 78